Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Il y a deux semaines,
j’étais en Irlande du Nord
et j’ai visité les studios
de Game of Thrones.
C’est un peu comme un musée
avec les décors des villes inventées,
les costumes des personnages
et plein d’autres objets
façonnés tout spécialement pour la série.
Là bas, on peut vraiment constater
tout le travail créatif
qui a mené à toutes ces productions.
Des idées aux dessins,
des dessins aux maquettes
et des maquettes
aux réalisations concrètes.
Chaque motif de vêtement,
chaque gravure
sur chaque casque de chevalier
et même chaque couleur et texture
de chaque façade de chaque maison
reconstruite pour la série.
Tous ces détails qu’on voit passer
à l’écran sont en fait le résultat
de processus créatif
extrêmement complexes,
impliquant des milliers d’individus
spécialisés, par exemple,
dans l’architecture,
dans le design graphique,
dans la couture, dans les effets spéciaux.
Là-bas, j’ai vraiment constaté
à quel point
les humains peuvent être passionnés
par des histoires de fiction.
On est passionné au point de motiver
des milliers d’individus
- experts dans plein de domaines -
à collaborer pendant des années
pour produire une série.
On est aussi passionné au point
de motiver des investisseurs
et les producteurs
à investir énormément d’argent.
Dans le cas de Game of Thrones,
près d’un milliardde dollars
pour produire une série, non seulement
pour payer tous ces experts,
mais aussi les matières premières
et les technologies nécessaires.
Et on est nous-mêmes motivés à regarder
un écran pendant très longtemps,
à dépenser notre argent
pour avoir accès aux épisodes
et à se coordonner avec nos amis
pour les regarder ensemble.
Je vous parle de Game of Thrones
parce que je suis allé dans ce musée,
mais j’aurais bien pu vous parler
de plein d’autres histoires de fiction
comme Star Wars, Harry Potter, One Piece,
Desperate Housewives et j’en passe.
Le monde entier est rempli
d’histoires de fiction,
que ce soit des romans,
des films, des séries,
des jeux vidéo, des mangas ou des animés.
Pour mieux comprendre ce phénomène,
je vous invite tous et toutes
à faire une expérience de pensée.
Nous allons tous imaginer, ici,
que nous sommes des extraterrestres.
Nous approchons de la Terre
pour étudier toutes les espèces animales
qui sont présentes sur cette planète.
On se rend compte qu'il y a
beaucoup de similarités.
Ils dorment,
communiquent,
forment des liens sociaux,
construisent des maisons et des habitats,
construisent des outils,
rivalisent pour des ressources,
s’occupent de leur progéniture
et adaptent leur comportement
en fonction de leur environnement.
Mais en observant d’un peu plus près
une espèce en particulier,
on trouve quelque chose de très étrange.
Les membres de l’espèce humaine
passent un temps fou
immergé dans des histoires
qu’ils savent être complètement inventées.
Qu’est-ce qui les pousse à faire ça ?
Et est-ce que tous les humains font ça ?
Pour répondre à cette dernière question,
on peut se pencher
sur les sociétés de chasseurs-cueilleurs.
Ce sont ces sociétés
qui, encore aujourd’hui,
vivent principalement de chasse,
de pêche et de cueillette
et qui n’ont pas adopté
ni l’agriculture, ni l’élevage.
L’étude de ces sociétés est intéressante
car elle nous offre un aperçu
du mode de vie
que pouvaient avoir nos ancêtres
avant l’émergence des sociétés modernes.
Il faut bien réaliser que depuis
l’émergence de notre lignée,
les hominidés,
il y a sept millions d’années
et jusqu’à l’invention de l’agriculture,
il y a à peu près 10 000 ans,
tous nos ancêtres vivaient
de chasse, de pêche et de cueillette,
comme ces chasseurs-cueilleurs.
C’est le mode de vie
qui a caractérisé nos ancêtres
pendant 99 % de leur évolution.
Et le mode de vie que nous avons
dans les sociétés industrialisées,
qui repose en fait sur l’agriculture
et la technologie,
représente les 1 % restants.
Nous avons donc beaucoup à apprendre
de ces sociétés de chasseurs-cueilleurs,
non seulement pour savoir d’où on vient,
mais peut-être, je vais essayer de montrer
ce qui a façonné nos histoires préférées.
Revenons à notre question :
« Est-ce que les fictions
sont universelles ? »
L’anthropologue Polly Weissner
s’est intéressée
à ces sociétés de chasseurs-cueilleurs
depuis plus de 40 ans
en allant sur place,  à leur rencontre.
Dans une étude publiée en 2014,
elle a notamment récolté et analysé
un grand nombre de leurs conversations.
Et elle a montré que le jour,
ces chasseurs-cueilleurs discutent
principalement de sujets pratiques
liés aux ressources
ou aux relations sociales du groupe.
Mais lorsque la nuit tombe et que les gens
se rassemblent autour du feu,
les conversations
se transforment radicalement
et ce sont les histoires
qui deviennent prédominantes.
Elles représentent
près de 80% des conversations.
On peut donc penser que bien avant
l’émergence de la société moderne,
il y a 10 000 ans,
les humains se racontaient
déjà des histoires autour du feu
le soir après une journée de travail.
On peut reprendre
le point de vue des extraterrestres.
Dans notre vaisseau spatial,
on s’est rendu compte
que tous les humains,
depuis sûrement des dizaines
de milliers d’années,
se racontent des histoires de fiction.
Première conclusion à ce stade, la fiction
est universelle chez les humains,
quelles que soient leur époque
et leur culture.
On peut donc poursuivre notre enquête.
Pour comprendre pourquoi
cette fascination pour les fictions
est universelle,
nous allons nous intéresser
à ce que les humains se racontent.
Est-ce que le contenu de ces histoires
est lui aussi universel ?
Les historiens de la littérature
ont depuis longtemps repéré les thèmes
qui transcendent les époques
et les frontières.
On va prendre trois exemples les monstres,
les histoires d'amour et les voyages.
D'abord les monstres.
Il y a des récits de monstres
et de créatures fantastiques
dans toutes les cultures avant même
qu’elles ne rentrent en contact.
On peut prendre un exemple frappant,
celui des dragons.
Les dragons ont été imaginés
dans plusieurs civilisations simultanément
et de façon indépendante.
On retrouve des traces de cette créature
pourtant imaginaire il y a 3000 ans
en Mésopotamie, chez les Sumériens et
en Amérique centrale, chez les Aztèques,
mais aussi en Chine ancienne,
au Japon et en Grèce antique.
Deuxième exemple, l’amour.
Les histoires d’amour ont captivé
les humains depuis des millénaires
à travers les époques et les cultures.
On peut citer deux exemples majeurs
Roméo et Juliette
et les amants papillons, en Chine.
Et dans ces deux histoires,
les couples préfèrent mourir
plutôt que d'être séparés.
Enfin, les voyages.
Dans de très nombreuses histoires,
il y a des personnages
qui voyagent dans des mondes inconnus.
On peut penser à l’Odyssée d’Homère,
mais aussi à l’épopée de Soundjata,
un récit de l’empire du Mali
raconté par les griots
ou les conteurs d’Afrique de l’Ouest.
Remettons-nous dans la peau
de ces extraterrestres.
On s’est rendu compte
de quelque chose d’encore très étrange.
Partout dans le monde
et à toutes les époques,
les histoires que les humains se racontent
contiennent des thèmes très similaires,
comme par exemple l’amour,
les voyages et les monstres.
Parfois, c'est même tout en même temps.
Tous les humains semblent connaître
ce personnage
qu’ils appellent Harry Potter.
Et dans cette histoire, Harry Potter,
ce personnage voyage,
s’oppose à des monstres et tombe amoureux.
Comment expliquer qu’il y ait
autant de thèmes universels
et que le contenu des histoires
soit universel
dans les histoires
que les humains se racontent ?
Pour mieux comprendre,
il faut s’intéresser à cet organe
que nous avons tous entre les oreilles
et que tous les membres
de notre espèce ont entre les oreilles,
depuis l’avènement d’homo sapiens.
Depuis 200 000 ans, tous les humains
développent ce même cerveau.
Pour mieux le comprendre,
on peut tenter une analogie
et le comparer à un smartphone.
Le smartphone comme le cerveau,
c’est une sorte de machine plutôt complexe
qui effectue des tâches
plus ou moins difficiles
grâce à des applications.
Pour le smartphone,
l’application de l’application téléphone
permet de téléphoner.
Grâce à l’application note,
on peut prendre des notes
et avec l’application calculatrice,
on peut faire des calculs.
Pour le cerveau, c'est la même chose.
Et les scientifiques appellent
les applications dans le cerveau :
des programmes cognitifs.
Par exemple, grâce au programme du dégoût,
les humains restent à distance
de ce qui pourrait être
porteur de maladies.
Grâce au sens de l'orientation.
Un autre programme,
les humains s’oriente dans l’espace.
Ces deux programmes sont donc
comme des applications dans notre cerveau.
Quand vous achetez un smartphone,
il arrive avec
des applications préinstallées
et sans ces applications,
l’appareil ne servirait pas à grand chose.
C’est l’hypothèse
qu’on fait pour le cerveau.
Il ne servirait à rien
sans des programmes préinstallés.
Et l’idée, c’est que l’évolution
a sélectionné des programmes
qui sont les plus utiles pour régler
des problèmes récurrents
dans notre évolution
et liés à la survie ou à la reproduction.
Il ne nous reste plus qu’à identifier
quelques uns de ces problèmes
et à essayer de comprendre
comment ces programmes
façonnent les histoires
que nous nous racontons.
On va reprendre les trois exemples
universels de tout à l’heure :
les monstres, les histoires d’amour
et les voyages.
D'abord les monstres.
J’ai mentionné des monstres
dans la littérature ancienne
mais il y a des monstres dans beaucoup
de fictions populaires modernes.
Par exemple, on peut penser
aux créatures dans Predator
ou dans Alien
et enfin à Godzilla.
J’aurais pu préciser depuis le début
que je n’utilise pas des images
des vrais films et séries
pour des problèmes de droits
mais j’utilise des images
parfois régénérées
par l’intelligence artificielle.
Mais je me suis assuré
qu’elles étaient fidèles
par rapport aux images
que je voulais utiliser.
Donc la question c’est, pourquoi il y a
autant de monstres dans les histoires ?
La première réponse,
c’est qu’on aime se faire peur.
Des psychologues comme
Matthias Klassen et Colton Scrivener
ont montré que s’intéresser
à des menaces potentielles
était important pour notre survie.
Si important et depuis si longtemps
que ça constitue
un premier problème adaptatif
récurrent dans notre environnement
et lié à notre survie.
En réponse à ce problème adaptatif,
l’évolution a sélectionné un programme
qui nous permet de détecter les menaces
et de détecter tout ce qui pourrait
nous faire du mal, comme les serpents.
Les humains ne sont pas
les seuls à avoir évolué
un programme de reconnaissance
des prédateurs et des sources de menaces.
Les éthologues, les scientifiques
du comportement ont par exemple montré
que les antilopes observent avec intérêt
les guépards, pourtant leurs prédateurs,
quand ce n’est pas trop dangereux,
quand les guépards ne sont pas
en position de prédation.
C’est l’hypothèse qu’on fait
pour les fictions.
Pour les antilopes et les guépards,
cette habitude leur permet d’accumuler
de l’information au sujet des guépards
et donc de mieux réagir
face à eux dans le futur.
L’hypothèse pour les fictions d’horreur,
c’est qu’elles nous offrent
la même opportunité
de nous préparer à des prédateurs
alors que la source de la menace
n’est même pas présente.
Mais ce programme, dans notre esprit,
n’est pas sensible à toutes les menaces
de la même façon.
Le plus frappant, c’est que les créatures
des histoires ne ressemblent pas
à ce qui est responsable
du plus grand nombre de morts aujourd’hui.
Ces créatures fictionnelles
et ces monstres ressemblent
à ce qui a été responsable
du plus grand nombre de morts
pendant notre révolution.
Les créatures de ces histoires et
les  monstres ressemblent à ces prédateurs
que nos ancêtres ont dû affronter
pendant des centaines de milliers d’années
avec, par exemple,
leurs griffes tranchantes,
leurs dents toutes aussi tranchantes
et leurs pattes velues.
En fait, à force d’être confronté
à ces prédateurs durant leur évolution,
le programme de détection des prédateurs
s’est calibré
pour les détecter automatiquement.
C’est pour cela que vous connaissez
sûrement des gens
qui ont une phobie
des araignées ou des serpents,
alors même que vous ne connaissez
sûrement personne
qui est mort d’un serpent
ou d’une araignée.
À l’inverse, personne ne sursaute
ou ne se met à courir
à la vision d’une cigarette par exemple,
alors qu’il est bien plus probable
que vous connaissiez quelqu’un
qui est décédé d’avoir trop fumé.
Ce programme préinstallé
explique donc pourquoi les monstres
dans les fictions ressemblent
à des araignées ou à des reptiles
mais pas à des paquets de cigarettes.
Maintenant, parlons d'amour.
Les histoires d’amour et les relations
romantiques sont au cœur
d’énormément de fictions modernes comme
Bridgerton, La Vie d’Adèle, Titanic.
Pour expliquer ce succès,
il faut d’abord noter
que former des couples stables et durables
étaient un vrai atout durant l’évolution
non seulement pour notre survie,
mais aussi celle de notre progéniture.
Je ne sais pas si on est tous d’accord.
Je pense qu’on l’est.
Rester en couple longtemps.
C'est un vrai défi.
Un défi si important et si récurrent
durant notre évolution
que c’est un deuxième exemple
de problème adaptatif.
Pour résoudre ce problème, l’évolution
a sélectionné un programme supplémentaire
qu'on peut tout simplement appeler
l'amour romantique.
Des résultats en neurosciences suggèrent
que tous les humains
peuvent tomber amoureux
grâce à l’existence
de ce programme préinstallé.
Nous partageons d’ailleurs
avec de nombreux animaux
qui montrent tous les signes
qu’ils tombent eux aussi amoureux.
Deux individus se rencontrent,
apprennent à se connaître, se choisissent,
élèvent des enfants ensemble, s’entraident
et  restent ensemble jusqu’à la mort.
C’est le cas pour les éléphants,
pour les hippocampes,
mais aussi pour une espèce de perroquet
qu’on appelle pour cette raison :
les inséparables.
Comme l’a montré la psychologue,
Catherine Salmon,
les histoires d’amour
profitent de l’existence
de ce programme préinstallé
chez tous les humains
pour nous offrir des histoires romantiques
fascinantes.
Enfin, les voyages, les fictions
nous font souvent voyager
dans des univers fantastiques.
On peut penser à Hyrule, à Westeros,
à la Terre du Milieu, à Poudlard.
Pendant des centaines
de milliers d’années,
nos ancêtres devaient explorer
des mondes inconnus
pour trouver de nouvelles ressources,
trouver des informations
et assurer leur survie.
C’est un autre problème adaptatif
et un programme cognitif a donc évolué
pour nous pousser à explorer l’inconnu.
C’est un programme qu’on partage
d’ailleurs avec d’autres animaux
qui eux aussi parcourent
de longues distances
pour découvrir de nouvelles zones
de reproduction ou de nourriture.
Et ces individus, ces oiseaux, par exemple
vont explorer des environnements
qu'ils n'ont jamais explorés auparavant.
L’hypothèse que je défends
dans mon travail de thèse
avec mon directeur de thèse,
Nicolas Baumard,
c’est que les mondes imaginaires
activent ce programme préinstallé,
lié à l’exploration,
et nous sommes donc poussés
à vouloir les explorer.
Si nous étions donc des extraterrestres,
étudions l'espèce humaine.
Nous pourrions donc expliquer pourquoi
les humains sont fascinés
par des fictions.
Cette fascination universelle repose
sur la présence dans les histoires
d’éléments qui font écho
à des programmes préinstallés
dans tous les cerveaux humains.
Depuis des centaines de milliers d’années,
ces programmes nous permettent
de résoudre des problèmes adaptatifs
dans notre évolution, comme par exemple
repérer les prédateurs,
former des couples durables
ou explorer des environnements.
Les monstres, l’amour
et les mondes imaginaires
ne sont que quelques exemples.
Mon travail et celui
d’autres scientifiques
permet d’en explorer beaucoup d’autres.
Par exemple, le psychologue Daniel Nuttall
et l'anthropologue manager Siin
ont étudié comment la présence
de certains programmes cognitifs
préinstallés liés à l’amitié,
permet d’expliquer
et de comprendre notre intérêt
pour certains personnages de fiction.
Dans un travail de synthèse que je mène
avec de nombreux collaborateurs
et de nombreuses collaboratrices,
nous en avons identifié
environ 70 programmes préinstallés
qui, ensemble, pourraient
permettre de comprendre
pourquoi les fictions sont si diverses,
si riches et si captivantes.
Mon travail de recherche, c’est donc
d’essayer de mieux comprendre
les fictions grâce à notre compréhension
de l’esprit humain
et peut être même de mieux comprendre
l’esprit humain grâce aux fictions.
Merci beaucoup.